dana tell me if this upsets you david
was once on my show and i said david if
you could pick a saturday night live
cast take it and make it an all-star
cast and i wasn't
you weren't in it well i don't mind what
what was your all-time i don't know was
it a top
five written down no i'm going to tell
you well i think you're saying from all
time can you pick five people i didn't
know yeah yeah what did i pick i'll
probably agree well i want to hear your
all-time question you can leave david
out of yours yeah yeah but uh don't
leave me out
david's all-time cast oh let's see jesus
bill murray you can't argue with that
dan aykroyd i i think a great utility
player dan aykroyd right i mean funny
all the time kristen wait can't go wrong
with her kate mckinnon yeah mind-blowing
talent chris farley what can you say i
mean no-brainer
adam sandler come on adam is there any
limits to the cash how many did i get
this is some cash here's the cap here's
the next three names phil hartman tina
fey and norm mcdonald that was david's
wow oh really
i was shocked dana that david did not
choose shocked i almost fell off my
chair when i didn't hear the name dana
carvey i mean let's we didn't hear eddie
murphy and i love eddie murphy god damn
that look i'm not i'm not really
bothered by that
thanks howard
i thought i'd be on the list
oh i didn't have jan hooks did i you
know what it's more fun howard is
all-star team i pick my all-star my five
all-stars he picks his five all-stars
and then you decide which team would
kick the other team's ass okay i got
phil phil hartman power forward i got
bill hader driving in i got
boy i you know it's so hard between amy
poehler and kristen wiig and maya
rudolph they're so [ __ ] amazing okay
i'll go with kristen wick because she's
kind of norwegian so am i no belushi
well it's like it's either farley or
belushi right
for that okay so who do you go with do
you go with farley or do you go with
belluji well the way lorne did it at
least in the early days it was an
assortment pack so he didn't want to
repeat people so you'd want a character
voice guy i'm hearing a lot of
hesitation who do you choose between
chris farley and the great jumble
charlie
you take farley and farley yeah right
and finally would never believe that i
was sitting next to farley at one of the
anniversary shows and they were just
doing a montage of belushi who's
brilliant amazing and chris is like look
and i go chris
i think you might be a little bit better
he goes no no he got really mad he got
upset
only if you look now what is it 50 years
the one sketch that never disappoints
and always destroys me
is van down by the river the best
because i've never seen he was putting
so much into it david was losing it
which also made it funnier but the
commitment of that the rhythm of that
is so potent i don't know how anybody
you know his voice is so interesting
i mean it's just it's just you you see
it you go it it was
it was supernatural you can use these
questions on your podcast i'm putting on
the spot who we got to do
who was the best host of the the weekend
updates you know dan aykroyd
dennis miller dennis miller unbelievable
who was the best well because the era i
was on and i remember
you know the show we only remember the
best shows and the best sketches i
remember a lot of shows like by the time
we got to update
we sucked it was like the audience was
like what is this why did we go it's
late can we can we get it can we leave
now no you really should stay it's a
live television show and then dennis who
is i've i did a long car ride with
dennis once
and he just sat in the back and wrote
like a hundred great jokes
wow uh just just out of it so dennis for
me who's a little bit unheralded in a
way because
whatever the political theater is of the
day um i'd i'll have to go with him
he's right in christ's sakes his
attitude is so great going on howie
stern huh what's he doing laying in with
the questions trying to get the uh the
two cats bubbling up over there all
right gets get a wedge between the
spudler and d man all right